[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa tarde
gostam de ouvir histórias
nós também gostamos de ouvir histórias
desde essa época as histórias
funcionavam para nós como uma maneira de
nos fazer domingo mas hoje acredito que
as histórias fazem muito mais gente
ficar acordado eu vou começar a contar
pra vocês
a melhor história que eu conheço em 1986
um homem veio de moçambique um jovem de
quase 30 anos ele veio para moçambique
que estava ali na cidade de brasília que
em frança uma noz e resolveu então
revelar o seu filme de 36 poses
nesse mesmo dia uma moça também quis
revelar as suas formas
só resta a moça estava revelando as suas
fotos porque ela estava de partida para
os estados unidos para ficar com sua mãe
adotivo acontece uma coisa muito
interessante nem todas as histórias é
toda história tem um ponto chave
quando eles foram pegar essas fotos
o atendente trocou embaló ele recebeu a
foto dela e ela recebeu a foto dele cada
um para sua casa
só que não era como nos tempos de hoje
que a gente tem o exato em que pode
comunicar fácil eles tiveram que até o
posto telefônico mais próximo é combinar
essa troca quando combinou de fazer essa
troca ela abriu o envelope falou mas
peraí
estão faltando algumas rodas e ele disse
sim
estão faltando algumas fotos e eu vou te
devolver essa gente jantar hoje à noite
interessante né
acontece que eles foram jantar aquela
noite e começaram a trocar fotos e
começaram a trocar muitas coisas
começar a trocar genes e assim nasceu a
família mais bonita do mundo que é a
minha família
essa é a nossa história e com esse
começo eu fico pensando em quantas vezes
a gente se atrela pequenos pedaços e
começa a reclamar da vida né
poxa o cara trocou as minhas fotos e vou
fazer questão no facebook
poxa o cara trocou o meu deus minhas
fotos que vou fazer vou ligar pro com eu
vou reclamar e se a gente deixasse de
ser pessoas que reclamam e passássemos a
ser pessoas que vão atrás pra minha mãe
se render um casamento o que pode render
para você então se você deixar de ser
uma pessoa que reclama das coisas e
passa então a mudar essas coisas que te
incomoda
nós crescemos com esse espírito nossos
pais não tinham muito para nos oferecer
quando nós éramos pequenas mas eles nos
ensinar o valor da educação tanto que
nós começamos a estudar em casa e vamos
cumpri minha mãe nos ensinava ler e
escrever meu pai ensinava contas exatas
ea minha avó me ensinava inglês
eles nos colocaram novamente que a
educação era a coisa mais importante que
a gente tinha tanto é que aos 15 anos ao
sair do ensino médio entrei na faculdade
aqui na cidade de anápolis quando entrei
na faculdade a minha primeira aula foi
uma aula de anatomia com o professor
maravilhoso lorenzo itu e por causa da
aula dele eu tive total certeza do que
queria fazer da minha vida eu queria ser
professor universitário mas aquela mesma
semana também teve aula de genética e eu
vi uma coisa que foi um pouco
devastadora pra mim porque meu professor
disse o seguinte todos os seres humanos
são 99,5 por cento e iguais a todo mundo
o seu código genético era aí gente
mas são os 99,5 por cento iguais a todo
mundo que graça tem nisso a gente
investe tanto em ser diferente mas
parece que foi programada para ser igual
como então eu posso dar voz aos meus 0,5
por cento que a única coisa que eu tenho
é diferente de qualquer outra pessoa
esses nossos 0,5 por cento eles brigam
por voz
mas não é o bastante mais importante
o que o direito de falar é o privilégio
de ser ouvido compreendido e respondido
essa é a luta de milhares de mulheres
que temos conhecido durante esses anos
quando decidimos voltar nossa carreira
para as comunidades mais carentes do
mundo
sabíamos que encontra realidades
difíceis mas dentro de uma escala esse é
que eu posso colocar em escala as
mulheres são as principais vítimas
algo precisava ser feito começamos então
com ações pontuais de doação mas vieram
novos questionamentos do tipo que do até
quando do ar porque as necessidades eram
muitas e só entrasse nessa cadeia de
doação sem o mecanismo de auto sustento
daqui a um tempo seria os meus filhos do
ano para os filhos dessas mulheres sem
levar em consideração que eles têm a
mesma capacidade de produzir e de se
desenvolver e é por compartilhar uma
receita que tem respondido esses muitos
outros questionamentos é que estamos
aqui hoje o futuro tem sido moldado
através de quatro conceito simples mude
o seu mundo com café
isso mesmo gente cafezinho que você toma
quando você acorda pode mudar o mundo
nós vamos ensinar então como fazer um
café muito bom pra que você seja uma
pessoa que desde reclamar dos problemas
e seja ele um solucionador desses
problemas o primeiro ingrediente para a
gente nesse café é o coração porque o
coração porque durante olha para os
problemas do mundo a gente pensa que a
primeira solução vai ser a caridade
então a gente olha para as pessoas em
situação de problema de pobreza e
situação de miséria e fala
poxa que eu queria que fizessem por mim
se eu tivesse no lugar dela e aí você
pensa eu vou então do a minha roupa
usada
eu vou então dá um pouquinho do que eu
tenho vou dividir sua caridade faz a
caridade olha pra pessoa que pensa o que
eu vou fazer por ela
sam se eu estivesse no lugar dela mas
quando a gente troca esse ingrediente da
caridade e passa a olhar com o coração
você vai entender que não é o suficiente
você olhar para aquela pessoa pensar o
que eu posso fazer por ela
a pergunta o contrário quando a gente
olha pro coração a gente pensa o que eu
tenho que fazer para que essa pessoa
esteja no meu lugar
o que eu posso fazer para que essa
pessoa discutiu os mesmos direitos que
eu porque enquanto a qualidade e vai nos
fazer tirar pior roupa do nosso guarda
roupa e doar para a cruz vermelha com
quem quer que seja a justiça social é
fazer é olhar para essa pessoa cansar
porque ela não consegue comprar uma
roupa nova como eu compro por nós
começamos a pensar nisso
nós pensamos em um projeto que é levar
desenvolvimento social com essas
mulheres ao redor do mundo ea idéia era
muito simples a maioria das mulheres que
nós temos contato hoje nós temos
projetos já desenvolvidos do nosso
portfólio já tivemos em 17 países e
essas mulheres muitas vezes não consegue
lidar com dinheiro não consegue nem ler
e escrever o que elas pensam as próprias
mãos
então vamos usar isso a idéia era então
usar o artesanato que é uma coisa mais
simples mais básica mais universal que
nós temos em todas as culturas e criar
uma escola móvel de corte costura e
artesanato para as mulheres que nós
encontraremos em situação de risco e
assim nasceu então a escola cook luba de
corte e costura artesanato visando
empoderamento econômico das mulheres em
situação de risco ao redor do mundo
a segunda receita do nosso ingrediente é
a alma entender que são pessoas e não
números estatísticas faz toda a
diferença era mulheres sabíamos onde
elas viviam e quais eram os problemas
que enfrentavam a partir daí precisavam
se inscrever um projeto se teve alguma
coisa que identificamos em todas as
comunidades que visitamos era
habilidades manuais que dessas mulheres
era incrível como elas conseguiram
trazer ordem beleza mesmo estando em
meio ao caos
o artesanato e poderia sim ser uma
ferramenta só que tinha um problema
nós não entendemos nada de artesanato
nada denise muito menos costura
abrimos então edital na internet
recrutando voluntários para quem
quisesse trabalhar conosco e ficamos
empolgados com a quantidade de
inscrições que tivemos
só que nenhum era de artesanato ninguém
sabia fazer artesanato
foi aí que decidiu em seu protótipo
desse projeto vamos pra sala de aula
aprender
tempos depois nós estávamos preparadas
para dar aula para 30 mulheres na semana
de viajar recebemos uma ligação que era
na verdade sempre usou
oito mulheres quando chegamos lá e
quatrocentos e noventa e cinco mulheres
foi lindo mas foi assustador mulheres de
8 a 70 ou até de 8 até 78 anos e durante
as aulas foi incrível ver que meninas
estavam conversando entre si e falava-se
nossa com dinheiro dessas vendas vou
pagar minha faculdade
uma senhora em especial me chamou no
canto falou assim professora
eu trabalhei dois meses para ter o
dinheiro para poder pagar essas aulas a
pagar o transporte para até pra até pra
fazer essas aulas e na minha casa tem
sete crianças e nós comemos um dia sim
dia não
mas professora agora tenho emprego e eu
te prometo que a partir de agora minha
família vai comer todos os dias
histórias podem sim ser escrita com
agulhas não eram 495 mulheres eram
mulheres de uma comunidade que estavam
dispostos a pegar o retalho que a vida
deixou fazer uma peça e construir algo
bonito
isso aconteceu no ano passado no mês de
julho
como nós já estávamos preparados apenas
pra 180 alunos e acabou aparecendo 495
nosso material acabou ea pergunta era
como dar continuidade a isso nós fizemos
um levantamento e pensamos então e
naquela localidade tanto em luanda
quanto em um ângulo abrir dois até eles
só que pra gente a precisar de cerca de
30 mil reais
trinta mil reais era muito próximo que
ele tinha na conta 30 reais
então se você sabe o que fazer a conta a
diferença é só de mil reais
além disso acontecer algo muito
interessante durante essas aulas de no
mês de julho
uma das alunas veio pra gente perguntou
assim professora vocês estão fazendo
boneca e eu falei que ela não ligou nós
não estamos fazendo boneca adquira 36
anos ela veio brincando com a gente com
uma garrafinha pet e cabelos postiços na
boneca e ela olhava para aquela dela e
falava assim professora amanhã aquela
boneca não liga não vai ter uma boneca
quando eu respondia que na segunda vez
eu entendi que a gente poderia fazer
mais por ela apesar de não ter tanto
material
juntamos toda a equipe foi quase um
trabalho de parto assim porque nós
éramos 12 pessoas nos juntamos sete
horas sem internet sem molde e fizer
ali uma boneca que ganhou o prêmio
internacional de pior boneca do mundo
porque a gente não sabia fazer a boneca
tinha a barriga torna um braço era maior
que o outro
a pena maior que a outra ea gente não
conseguiu fazer de um jeito que o
pescoço dela ficasse reta
o boneco de pescoço quebrado quando
entregava entregou a boneca prague da
boneca fazia assim eu falava não vida a
gente brinca no brasil assim assegura no
pescoço
aquilo foi muito bom e foi o melhor que
ela tinha no momento mas voltando à
nossa crise não era o melhor que podia
oferecer
nós não queremos mais trabalhar com a
idéia de que o meu lixo ao luxo do outro
porque a vida daquele outro é tão
importante quanto a mim entendeu
nós votamos no brasil começamos a
aprender a fazer bonecas
só que as bonecas e só para doar a gente
cria as bonecas também pra cliente gerar
essa renda pra ele e então nós temos uma
conta muito básica nossos pais nos
ensinaram que não existem problemas
grandes a gente pode pegar esses grandes
problemas e dividir menores
na verdade não precisava de 30 mil reais
eu precisava apenas de três mil parcelas
de 10 reais contando com a quantidade de
dinheiro que a gente precisava pra ir
pra fazer mais 1500 bonecas porque nunca
mais eu queria dar uma boneca dessa pra
alguém
nós precisamos de 45 mil reais e
quarenta e cinco reais não é grande eu
só preciso de 4500 parcelas de 10 reais
qualquer o plano então fazer miniaturas
bonecas a mãos e vender por 10 reais
quanto a nós pensávamos vender 4500 como
que nós vamos fazer nós mesmos
enquanto tem três meses isso nós fizemos
no ano passado de agosto setembro
outubro até chegar o começo de novembro
na nossa casa mas trabalhava nós
trabalhamos fora
esse é o nosso hobby nós trabalhamos
todos os dias de 8 a 6
e aí começamos com nossos pais e eles
abriram as portas da nossa casa para que
qualquer pessoa de qualquer lugar que
tivesse no long que funciona pudessem
pra nossa casa a partir das sete da
noite e trabalhar com a gente até duas
três
horas da manhã em três meses nós tivemos
cerca de 600 voluntários
fizemos quatro mil 500 bonecas vendemos
a r$10 igrejas e paróquias shoppings
sites sinal rua tudo que você pode
pensar e conseguimos comprar as bonecas
nós fizemos mil e 500 bonecas dessas
graduação e compramos e compramos o
material então pra montar esses dois até
eles
o que eu tinha de lição de tudo isso o
terceiro ingrediente da nossa receita
nós já tínhamos o coração naquilo a
nossa alma já tinha entendido mas nós
precisamos ter força não dá só pra gente
se comover palestra após palestra a
notícia após notícia não fazer nada nós
precisamos empregar a nossa força até o
fim
aí o trabalho de 86 ótimo que você faz
de madrugada
aí mas é madrugada é mais um filme
interessante a gente maratona e maratona
então por que não usar força em favor
daquilo que a gente acredita último
ingrediente da nossa receita e que faz
sentido dar sentido a todos os outros é
um entendimento
quando você se dispõe a entender a
necessidade do outro aquela necessidade
passa a ser tão importante quanto a sua
e esse entendimento mudou tudo quando
ele passou a entender a realidade das
pessoas a gente viu que não quando a
gente pensa em moldar o futuro não é
simplesmente acreditar na próxima
geração a gente sempre deixa para depois
quando geralmente quando a gente fala de
moldar o futuro está pensando em
melhorar as crianças pra frente
mas essa comigo gente não existe um
futuro novo s1 passado a gente não vai
conseguir resultados melhores daqui pra
frente não consertar como ficou atrás
não tem como a gente pensar em melhorar
a vida das crianças pra frente as mães
delas continuarem sofrendo porque o
futuro é o que daqui a 10 20 anos
será que toda essa geração vai morrer 10
e 20 anos mais urgente do nada não
essas mulheres vão continuar existindo
daqui a 10 ou 20 anos
elas também são o futuro
quando falo que quero trabalhar para o
futuro não querendo falar aqui e vou
trabalhar pelos meus filhos porque eu
nem sei a gente não tem filho mas
trabalhando futuro quero trabalhar pelos
meus pais
eu quero trabalhar pela minha avó que
mora em moçambique e há pouco tempo
atrás não tinha nem energia elétrica nem
água encanada e ainda nem conheço
quando eu falo de trabalhar pelo futuro
eu não posso pensar no que está na
frente como se fosse uma tarefa para
quem vem quando falo de trabalhar no
futuro eu tenho que olhar para aqueles
que estão atrás e fazer pelo menos
chegar no presente porque senão cada vez
mais esse futuro vai ser mais seleto
mais seleto e mais elenco
essas nossas alunas parte delas
nós já temos hoje já passaram pelas
aulas do projeto que engloba mais de 600
alunos 28 delas já estão vivendo do
artesanato
nós começamos em julho do ano passado e
ela já tenha renda diz
três delas já ganharam bolsas de estudo
essa pedra com essa falta da nossa
última formatura a crise é quem está
falando
na foto agora é uma das professoras
quebra bem aqui na cidade de anápolis
ela trabalha durante todo o dia e à
noite ela pedia para fazer a as bonecas
com a gente
algum tempo atrás ela recebeu uma
ligação essa ligação era de uma menina
de angola que ligou no primeiro celular
que ela comprou fruto da venda de
artesanato
essas crianças saber das bonecas mas eu
não quero a boneca cento para elas
porque não acredito que existam pessoas
que nasceram só pra ganhar do que os
outros dão por isso as mães delas todas
aprender a fazer bonecas porque a
próxima com elas
esse é o relato que nós recebemos no
facebook há pouco tempo
peça feito por meio da arte manual faça
já a sua encomenda com muito orgulho eu
sou fruto do projeto que engloba é isso
que nós temos ganhado esse tempo tudo o
que nós podemos fazer cultura o qual vai
ser a resposta
eu não tenho pronta não sou salvador ela
não é salvadora de ninguém mas não
estamos aqui dizendo que nós estamos
mudando
futuro das outras pessoas o que estou
dizendo é que nós estamos falando com as
pessoas que elas sim podem mudar seus
próprios futuros e nós temos um
pouquinho disso pra vocês através do
seguinte
hum
[Música]
van
i
[Música]
e agora nós vamos voltar
nós estamos na fase de automatizar os
nossos ateliês
nós já temos três das seis máquinas que
a gente precisa
nós já temos um gerador para um dos dois
ateliês e falta falta sem muita coisa
mas não temos nenhum tipo de patrocínio
não sei patrocínio
nós muitas vezes deixamos de fazer
coisas que gostaria de fazer coisas que
a gente precisa fazer mas tudo isso
porque nós temos quatro ferramentas
muito poderosos que é o coração a alma à
força e entendimento de que nós não
vamos conseguir mudar o futuro a gente
não resolver as nossas pendências com o
passado
aquelas pessoas que ficaram lá atrás é
isso
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]